it's the prize of a lifetime if you
actually get it even though squid game
The Challenge filmed months ago that
sweet paycheck is nowhere to be seen
squid game took over the Netflix world
when it premiered on the streamer in
late 2021 it was so popular that the
streaming Giants decided to turn the
dystopian drama into a real life game
show squid game The Challenge sees a
host of competitors Jal and intensified
children's games in hopes of walking
away with a staggering $456 million in
the end player 287 real name my whan won
the competition and a massive sum of
cash I don't know whether to cry or to
cheer I don't know what to do well at
least that's how it seemed when the
show's debut season concluded since the
final episode of squid game The
Challenge arrived on Netflix on December
6th it has come to light that Wayland
still hasn't received the $456 million
she was promised she revealed as much
during a chat with the times saying I
feel like Tom Cruz and Jerry Maguire
show me the money show me the
money the reward for winning squid game
The Challenge is the second largest sum
ever offered up by a reality show just
under the American take on the X-Factor
which holds the top spot with a wobb $5
million we can only hope that Netflix
sends the funds whand away soon seeing
as it's been roughly 10 months since
filming concluded it may have been a
long time coming but when she does get
her prize money whan has a pretty good
idea of what she's going to do with it
even though she doesn't have the $ 4.56
million in her bank account just yet
Nothing is Stopping May whan from
planning out how she'll spend it when it
finally arrives she discussed her plans
during her chat with the times sharing
that a new home could be on the horizon
she said I'm thinking about a retirement
home somewhere we don't know where yet
and we are happy with where we are we
live on the water it's very peaceful
Wayan currently lives with her family in
Fairfax County Virginia I'm married with
two daughters and a granddaughter and
two beautiful dogs additionally way
Learners also expressed her intention to
do some charitable work with her squid
gain the challenge winnings she plans to
give some of the money to charities for
those in need as well as those
protecting wildlife and working to
combat climate change however whan
unfortunately noted that a fellow
contestants shouldn't expect a
consolation prize from her in their
squid game The Challenge contracts it's
explicitly stated that they're not to
share their earnings with their
competitors still she hopes to at least
stay in contact with some of the other
players from the show knowing that may
whan plans to do various kind and
thoughtful things with her could gain
the challenge money may seem a bit odd
to viewers on the program she's far from
giving going all in throughout season 1
to ensure she makes it to the end she
doesn't have much care regarding who she
has to shove out of the way if it means
Landing the 4.56 million whan talked
about her winning mindset during an
interview with Men's Health saying that
as soon as she stepped onto the set she
forced herself to be a different person
entirely she explained when I walked
into the dormatory for the first time I
thought the character I have as a person
is outside the dormatory and my new
persona in the dormitory is that of a
competitive person Wayan Likens the
shift in mindset to Dr C transformation
into Mr hide was she ruthless and in
some cases a bit Too Faced yes did this
approach pay off certainly at the end of
the day only one person could walk away
$456 million richer and whan did what
she had to to make sure she was that
individual squid game The Challenge
season 1 is now streaming exclusively on
[Music]
Netflix